I will now pronounce the verdict guilty
of being a witch
Oh
onion Oh be
the crystal of late and those in the
nominees for Best 3ds game on gamespot's
2014 Game of the Year awards all right
bunch of great games and I'm feeling the
two of you have played all of them 3ds
maniacs Justin hey Walter Peter Brown
great system man there's a lot of good
games out there I mean almost any of
these games I I think could be a winner
they're all just like such wonderful
experiences this is this has been a
great year to be a 3ds gamer what I want
to talk about first is bravely default
because we have a very active discussion
downstairs about this one yeah and
bravely default is a game that you have
songs something like 120 hours into yeah
just just maybe a little bit over yeah
half of which you seem to really enjoy
and then half of which you weren't so
sure about its bring the default
definitely has a moment that that
happens and people stop some people stop
liking the game entirely it gets very
tiresome and it drags on for a very long
time but but the mechanics of the game
are really what bring it up that make it
a nominee and make it such a memorable
experience no matter what problems I
have the the story the game itself the
gameplay is something but I know Peter
loved a lot yeah I mean so essentially
this game takes the classic like
turn-based you know Final Fantasy combat
but it introduces a system where you can
sacrifice taking a turn and present bank
it for later and in doing so you guard
yourself a little bit but then you also
have the ability to deliver multiple you
know successive hits in a row which for
some bosses I can heal themselves it's
very important to be able to do that and
so it becomes a game of strategy and
it's very you know it's sort of figuring
out whether or not it's the right move
is something that happens throughout the
game there's no point in the game in
which you can just go on line you can go
on autopilot if you cheat but if you're
playing normally any any monster can
beat you at any time yeah and then it's
also got a great job class system that's
a very reminiscent of final fantasy
tactics where essentially you pick a job
class but then beneath that you can
assign abilities from other classes that
you've already you know leveled up and
worked with in and then you know beyond
that just the music and the art in the
world are incredible like it's it's this
great sort of like ascetic that we got
with some of the final fantasy remakes
on the d/s but it's been you know it's
grown up now in the 3ds it's got more
performing
behind it and it just looks wonderful
like yeah it's a little cute and you
might say childish but that doesn't mean
that it's not expressive and in great to
look at and then the writing itself is
also doing so well done like as much as
I had to push myself at once I got to
that 40 50 hour more guy to push myself
official but oh my god I wanted to play
the sequel so much because there's a
trailer that plays at the end that makes
you want to play that this equal to this
game okay well you mentioned Final
Fantasy a bunch of times there as well
theatrhythm not a game i played why do
you think it made it on these lists so
that so the rhythm is the second game in
the series and it's essentially a rhythm
game where you tap on the screen you do
a little gestures or you can use buttons
and you're doing this two songs from
soundtracks of old final fantasy games
so on the one hand it's a game built for
people who love this series yeah clearly
but this music is so good on its own
that it you don't have to be a fan of
the series to appreciate it i think you
get more out of it if you recognize the
characters and the worlds and the songs
but at the same time like it's a good
rhythm game it's got great music and
expressive little world and contrary to
you know it takes the first game and
then adds like a bunch of like little
RPG elements on top of it that
incentivize you to play even more and
make the game more challenging it's just
it's a lot of fun and there's a lot of
content there too yeah that's the thing
that makes you keep playing it I mean
it's not just the gameplay which is
similar to the first game but which was
so good I mean we haven't gotten another
elite beat agents game which was yeah
the high water mark for rhythm game zone
into yes this is basically like a
spiritual successor in some ways but
with completely new and different modes
but says RPG elements and getting to
level up your character and and having
that thing that makes you want to to get
to know your characters better take keep
using the same character over and over
again and you can get quip items
in-stock you go through dungeons that
have multiple paths that you can revisit
with different team members I mean
there's just a lot there at 2014 also
saw the sort of the culmination of two
DS fan favorites or combination the
cooperation confrontation confrontation
elaboration collaboration the hot
collabo of mr. professor layton and mr.
Phoenix rotting mr. professor I remember
when they announced Phoenix Wright vs
Professor Layton yeah and I thought it
was an april fool's joke but there is no
there's no way this game is real and
then i was so excited when it was real
and the game lives
to that hype in so many ways I mean it's
it's a fun story because it combines
that art style of the latent games and
the Phoenix Wright games which have
great cinematics and it gives you a
little bit of gameplay of both of them
because i love the puzzles and i love
the story of the phoenix wright games
and mashing up up up together as it's
peanut butter and chocolate another fan
favorite that returned this year as
super smash bros and not only made it to
we you but of course it came out on the
3ds as well yeah and i think you know
it's like a game that's traditionally
reserved for consoles and considering
you know what they're working with the
3ds they pulled it off like it it's not
necessarily the preferred you know
version of the game for people who
really like smash but just in like a
world of its own it's a great little
fighting game on the 3ds that kind of is
one of the more impressive games on the
system I think from a technical level
yeah if this had come out at the same
time as the wii u version there probably
wouldn't haven't been as many people who
would buy both but the fact that they do
you have things that carry over between
the versions like the characters that
you create you can bring your me
character and the things that you
collect put them onto the wii u version
it gives you an incentive to play the
3ds version even once the week now that
the Wii U versions out and I still go
back to my 3ds version and there's the
street past games that are built into it
as well that I like collecting those
things i like getting the little
challenges which are separate between
the two versions of the game it's it's
something that gives you a reason to
keep coming back to it and last but
certainly not least a game has been
popular on a bunch of platforms here in
the game spot offers a shovel knight
yeah one of the best platformers of all
time it is just such a great soul order
mr. Hale a very tall order it is i would
def in this to the death i know that
that Peter does not completely agree
with me and we came to blows in our
meeting but it's it's just such a lovely
game like the the art style is
reminiscent of those 8-bit and Nintendo
games but it adds gameplay and it adds
things of course you could never do on
in an NES game yeah i mean like we
argued about it because we were trying
to figure out like what would make the
nominees list but i do think shovel
knight is a great game and it it
incorporates a lot of things from well
you know like megaman you've got a
little bit of dark souls Elda to you got
dark souls in there with the the death
and a rebirth system where you you go
back to collect your stuff after you die
kind of like souls but ya know I mean
it's exactly witty writing great boss
battles great little
it's a great game I'm glad it made the
list I'm just glad that bravely default
also made it necessary there five great
nominees and we won't have to wait too
long to find out who wins December
twelfth on gamespot com is when we will
reveal our 3ds game of the airshow make
sure you check back to the site then